بمبادره من الشيخه موزه بنت ناصر رئيسه
مجلس اداره مؤسسه قطر للتربيه والعلوم
وتنميه المجتمع تم تدشين مركز ومسجد يحمل
اسم المجادله بهدف تعزيز الهويه الاسلاميه
للنساء وتوعيتهن بامور دينهن ودنياه ليشكل
مساحه مجتمعيه لهن المركز بحسب الشيخ موزه
سيشكل نموذجا يحتذى به للنساء اللواتي
السعين الى النهوض بمجتمعه من داخل
منظومته الدينيه والثقافيه والحضاريه لا
نجتمع هنا اليوم الاحتفال بجماليات
المعماريه للمبنى او من ثم تحويله لمزار
سياحي انما تصليب الضوء على مفهوم العداله
في العباده من خلال انشاء مركز ومسجد يتيح
للمراه تطوير ذاتها في الشؤون الدينيه
والدنيويه من منظور شرعي وفهم شامل
للعباده حتى لا تبقى مصليات ال نساء مهمشه
وزويه في ركن في ركن
قصي بوضع لا يليق بقيمه المسجد الروحيه
والايمانيه بما يجعلها بيئه غير جاذبه
للفتيات ضيف الشرف في حفل الافتتاح
الداعيه والمفكر الاسلامي الدكتور عمر عبد
الكافي اشار في كلمته الى اهميه انشاء مثل
هذه المراكز في دعم هويه المراه المسلمه
والنهوض بها بعد فترات طويله من التهميش
نحن
بهذا الشيء العظيم
الذي يفتتح اليوم
حقيقه تستنهض همه المجتمع الاسلامي بعد
نوم قارب القرون الاربعه عندما همش دور
المراه المركز المخصص للنساء سيستضيف طيفا
من الانشطه وسيوفر برامج باللغتين العربيه
والانجليزيه ستتنوع بين الدورات وورش
العمل وجلسات التاريخ الاسلامي والشريعه
الاسلاميه والبحوث وقد تم تزويده فصول
دراسيه ومكتبه واماكن للتجمع ومقهى وحدائق
ومن خلال مساحه التعبد والتعلم سيكون مركز
المجادله مصدرا لالهام كل امراه تريد ان
تكون على بينه وترغب في مزيد من التطور
والارشاد واستنباط الحلول من داخل الاسلام
برؤيه ملائمه لتحديات الحاليه مركز ومسجد
المجادله سيشكل فضاء اوسع للمراه يساهم في
دراسه الدين الاسلامي في سياقه التاريخي
والمعاصر مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الاحتياجات المتنوعه لها ساره رشيد
الجزيره
الدوحه